hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today
we have a bit of a short video but i did
want to go over a few bits of
information that was released today just
some small things that you might want to
know little tidbits of information
and just a little recap of what the [ __ ]
has been going on the past day or so
because i've released like three
different
videos so i want to explain that so it's
always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new
i cover the informational side of for
honor and with that let's get started
with today's video
so yes today is august 6th that means
the new hero and the new event is
live rise of the warmonger and then the
new hero warmonger of course
if you haven't seen any of this stuff
you can click the i in the top right and
that will take you to my three videos
covering the aforementioned topics that
will be shown
the event battle pass the new hero the
weapons the armored the executions the
emotes etc literally everything you need
to know about this season
it's all gonna be in those three early
access videos on top of that stuff also
releasing
there's the year four season two title
update two we covered this i think a
couple weeks ago i think in the very
large video like i think about a week
and a half ago
this had to do with more of the core
combat updates some of the testing
ground changes
and stuff like that so that'll also be
linked in the top right if you want to
see that video
on screen you're going to be seeing some
things with twitch drops this has been a
thing that they've been doing for the
past year so so let's dissect this
on the top right it's gonna be saying
stuff like watch one hour two hour four
six twelve and twenty four as long as
you go on the twitch directory which
just type in for honor on twitch and
there will be all those streamers there
right underneath their name should say
something drops enabled or not drops
enabled as long as it says drops enabled
and you have linked your ubisoft account
to your twitch
everything is all set you can just watch
that streamer for as long as you want
go to the next streamer it does not
matter as long as it's 24 hours within
the next week or so you are totally fine
doesn't have to be the same one doesn't
have to be altogether
you could do two hours now two hours
later and then the rest of the 20 at the
very last day if you wanted to as long
as it's a total of 24 hours
you'll get all of those rewards seen on
screen as it's cumulative
the stuff on the left is for the last
couple days of the week if you're in one
of those streams as the ones that i've
mentioned before the one that i've
dropped enabled
and you are within the stream on those
specific days and times of course it's
different per time zone you'll be
getting xp boost for those times so
you'll be getting
four xp boosts at 12 pm est on august
10th and then another at 3 pm or 3 hours
later
of course depending on your time zone
and then the same thing on august 11th
and then the same on august 12th which
gives you
a shitload of xp boost that you can use
for warmonger
and then the bottom right is for the
streamers that want to use those twitch
drops those are going to be for the
people that really want to grind out
that steel
the top 10 streamers in terms of time
streamed on twitch not v this has
nothing to do with your account it is
strictly about the
time spent in the stream actually
playing moment 100 thousand steal and
anybody could do this you could have one
viewer for the entire time but you could
just stream 60 hours and you would
definitely be eligible next up is the
road map and of course august 6th we
have the for honor
warmonger hero we have the title update
we talked about we have the rise of the
warmonger
up event we have the free event pass we
have the twitch drops directory
and we have new arcade with new content
which we'll be getting into
august 7th with the day after is double
xp so solid stuff exactly when warmonger
releases perfect timing
for august 8th we have a new ending of
the campaign we're almost done
the 13th there's going to be some arcade
stuff with content the 20th
is going to be arcade and content and
then also the free version essentially
of when warmonger releases because as we
stated before
warmonger is going to be releasing on
august 6th for eight dollars but if you
don't want to pay you
are then going to have to wait a couple
weeks and purchase her on the 20th for
15 000 steel
22nd we'll figure out who wins the
faction war the 27th is gonna be
throwback stuff carousel of death and
then
a carousel of death challenge with some
rewards from the right of champions not
really sure what that means i don't know
if that's just like some of the content
or some of the mask outfits they had but
we'll have to see when it gets to that
date and then on the 28th we get an
extra loofast so perfect way to kind of
start the new part of the month the very
last thing is the content of the week
and that is the mask outfits and then
the execution
there are two new mask outfits the
belligerent sheep and the bellerin alpha
one of them is a sheep
one of them is a wolf and that's
depending on which one you want to pay
for obviously i'm definitely team
sheep i get it you know no alpha stuff
with you know the sheep and the wolves
that apollyon has been preaching
but i think the sheep is too damn cute
not to pick and the execution is also
two different types
it's random kind of like the sword and
the stone one we had like years ago
that one it's just like that it's random
every time you execute the person
your character will do one of two
different executions either they kick
them or they cut their head off and it's
totally random and there is no way to
actually get the correct one that you
want
it's just kind of up to you know luck
and i think it's really cool they add
these and i hope they do more of them
but yeah but that stuff is probably
still playing in the background i'm
gonna do the outro
of course if it's still playing i'll let
that play and then we'll cut to the
outro but as always
like the video enjoy i gotta subscribe
if you're new enjoy the new warmonger
hero i cannot wait to play her as
i've been playing her in early access
she is a ton of fun to play and that
take care enjoy the busted feats
and peace out
[Music]
you